la corona manche können dieses wort
schon gar nicht mehr hören anderen macht
ist richtige angst was macht diese krise
mit unserer psyche darüber spreche ich
jetzt mit professor dr borwin bandelow
er ist psychologe und experte für
angststörungen herzlichen guten tag und
auch in sie die frage was macht denn
diese krise die jetzt schon so lange für
uns alle dauerte mit unserer psyche
guten tag frau platin die das böse
corona wort können manche leute gar
nicht mehr hören obwohl überall die
zahlen astronomische ansteigen sind die
leute aber kroner müde und sie wollen
nicht mehr leben so weiterführen wie
bisher und das führt dazu dass die
ratschläge der politiker einfach an uns
abgleiten und dass wir uns selber unser
risikoprofil jetzt zurecht legen das
heißt dass jeder für sich also ich sage
das kann ich machen und das kann ich mir
nicht leisten da sollte ich besser nicht
hingehen aber was die politiker sagen
ist mir eigentlich egal wie gehen wir
denn jetzt damit um wenn das aller
voraussicht nach die nächsten monate
noch so bleibt diese unsichere situation
dieses wirrwarr von dem sie sprachen ja
es scheint ja so als ob die politiker
sich widersprechen das liegt aber
teilweise daran dass natürlich die
risikolage in mecklenburg vorpommern
ganz anders aussieht als in bayern und
deswegen können sie sich nicht einigen
das führt jetzt wiederum viele menschen
dazu dass wir denken ja die politiker
dieser amazonas
wir wissen nicht was wahr ist also mache
ich das ja zu wie ist wie es mir passt
und die angst entwickelt sich jetzt mehr
so nach den erfahrungen der menschen
viele menschen haben eben bisher noch
nicht die erfahrung gemacht dass ein
angehöriger oder freund oder bekannter
gestorben ist durch corona oder schwer
erkrankt ist und weil sie unsere sieht
das noch für theoretisch ist schon für
viele leute denken sie jetzt werde ich
einfach mein leben trotzdem
normalisieren obwohl eigentlich die
datenlage ganz anders aussieht im moment
wenn jetzt der korona blues oder im
schlimmsten fall sogar die korona angst
zuschlägt haben sie denn ganz
pragmatische tipps für uns wie man
dadurch kommt es ja immer wieder die
rede von frischer luft der ernährung der
schlag soll eine rolle spielen was hilft
uns gegen die angst ich kann ja den
menschen ganz schlecht empfehlen trinken
sie jetzt erst mal schön einen grünen
tee und beruhigen sie sich wieder nein
wir müssen diese angst aushalten lernen
es ist ja eine reale angst es ist nicht
wie bei einer angst vor einer harmlosen
spinne die man einfach überwinden kann
oder so sondern das ist eine angst sie
da ist und dann kann man sie den
menschen nicht nehmen werden müssen in
der nächsten zeit einfach damit umgehen
lernen und der einzige tipp den ich dann
geben kann ist erfolgt und ein gesunder
fatalismus ehrfurcht weil das virus
nicht sehr gefährlich sein kann aber
auch ein gesunder fatalismus man muss
sich einfach ausrechnen dass wir eben
einzelnen von uns die chance morgen
corona infiziert zu werden
relativ gering ist das heißt nicht dass
wir unvorsichtig sind aber dass wir auch
nicht völlig für geängstigt
unser leben jetzt führen sollen in den
nächsten monaten wo ist denn die feine
linie zwischen einer normalen angst und
an einer angststörung wie kann ich dann
zum beispiel selber bemerken wenn meine
angst die kontrolle gewinnt über mich ja
die übergeben wir können fließen sein
bei denen angsterkrankungen machen wir
eigentlich ihr vorhaben losen dingen
angst wie zb fahrstühlen oder mäusen
oder angst sich zu blamieren
das sind so die angst krankheiten auf
der anderen seite gibt es die realen
ängste und der unterschied ist eben ja
wenn ich jetzt zum beispiel bei einer
angst krankheit 50 prozent des tages
über die ans nachdenken muss wenn ich
anfange beruhigungsmittel oder alkohol
im übermaß zu mehr zu nehmen
und wenn ich massive einschränkungen im
sozialen leben oder familienleben oder
sogar auch im berufsbereich habe dann
wäre es zeit sich in behandlung zu
begeben
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schaue ich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren